welcome to my presentation on level
three linear yeah
level three linear equations okay so let
me let's let's make up a problem let's
say I had X plus 2 X plus 3 is equal to
minus 7x minus 5 well in all of these
linear equations the first things that
we the first thing that we try to do is
get all of our variables on one side of
the equation and then get all of our
constant terms on the other side of the
equation and then it actually will
become a level 1 linear equation so the
first thing we can do is we could try to
simplify each of the sides
well we on this on this left side we
have this X plus 2x well what is X plus
2x well that's like saying I have one
Apple and now I have two apples so here
I have One X and now I have two more X's
and I'm adding together so that equals
3x 3x plus 3 is equal to minus 7x minus
5 now let's bring the 7x over on to the
left hand side and we can do that by
adding 7x to both sides
7x this is a review we we're adding the
opposite so it's negative 7x so we add
7x so that's why and we do that because
on the right side these two will cancel
and the left side we get 10 X plus 3
equals and on the right side all we have
left is the negative 5 almost there now
we're at a level was it's a level two
problem and now we just have to take
this 3 and move to the other side we can
do that by subtracting 3 from both sides
that's a 3 minus 3 the left-hand side
the threes cancel out that's why we
subtract it three in the first place and
you have 10x equals and then minus 5
minus 3 well that equals minus 8 now
we just multiply both sides of this
equation by 1 over 10 or the reciprocal
of 10 which is the coefficient on X
times one over ten you could also some
people will say well we're just dividing
both sides by 10 which is essentially
what you're doing if you divide by 10
that's the same thing as multiplying by
1 over 10 well anyway the left hand side
1 over 10 times 10 well that equals 1 so
we're just left with x equals negative 8
over 10 that can be reduced further they
both share the common factor 2 so you
divide by 2 so it's minus 4 over 5 I
think that's right assuming that I
didn't make any careless mistakes let's
do another problem let's say I had 5
that's a 5x minus 3 minus 7x equals x
plus 8 and in general if you want to
work this out before I give you how I do
it now's a good time to actually pause
the video and you could you could try to
work it out and then play it again and
see what I have to say about it but
assuming you want to hear it let me go
and do it so let's do the same thing we
first of all we can merge these two x's
on the left hand side remember you can't
add the 5 and the 3 because it's 3 is
just a constant term while the 5 is 5
times X but the 5 times X and the
negative 7 times X you can merge so 5
you just add the coefficient so it's 5
and negative 7 so that becomes negative
2x minus 3 is equal to X plus 8 now if
we want to take this X that's on the
right hand side and put over the left
hand side we just subtract X from both
sides
the left-hand side becomes minus three X
minus three is equal to these two x's
cancel out it's equal to eight now we
can just add three to both sides to get
rid of that constant term three on the
left-hand side these two threes will
cancel out you get minus three X is
equal to eleven now you just multiply
both sides by negative one-third and
once again this is just the same thing
as dividing both sides by negative three
and you get x equals negative 11 over
three actually let's let's just for fun
let's check this just to see and the
cool thing about algebra is if you have
enough time you can always make sure you
got the right answer so we have 5x so we
have five times negative 11 over three
so that's I'm just I'm just going to
take this and substitute it back into
the original equation and you might want
to try that out too so you have minus 55
over three that's just five times
negative 11 over three that's a 3 minus
3 and what's 3 3 could also be written
as minus 9 over 3 I'm skipping some
steps but I think you know your
fractions pretty good by this point so
that's minus 9 over 3 and then minus 7x
is the same thing as plus 77 over 3
because we have the minus 7 times minus
11 so it's plus 77 and and the equation
is saying that should equal minus 11
over 3 that's what X is plus 1/8 is
nothing but other than 24 over 3 let's
add this up minus 55 minus 9 that's
minus 64 if I'm right yeah that's minus
64 and then plus 77 minus 64 plus 77 is
13 so the left-hand side becomes 13
over three and then the right hand side
minus 11 plus 24 well that's 13 and we
still have over three so looks like we
got the right solution it checks out so
the correct answer was minus 11 over 3
hopefully you're ready by now to do some
level 3 problems the only thing that
makes us a little bit more complicated
than level 2 is you just have to
remember to merge the variables in the
beginning and know that you could
subtract variables or constants from
both sides have fun